so if a politician I'll give you kind of
a loaded question you can take whatever
you want but if a politician was
listening to this and God knows like all
the politicians in the country listen to
this podcast
what would be a benefit to them
embracing it besides just the fact that
well if we can't get rid of it we might
as well just go along with it like is
there a pitch to governments of like you
should want this rather than want it
because all your citizens want it and
it'll help you get elected is there a
reason that Bitcoin does good things for
governments or is it just that it
because the people are happy ultimately
that flows up to the government if that
makes sense
well I personally believe that the
government serves the will of the people
and the people are protected by the U.S
Constitution Bill of Rights Etc and
Bitcoin is the equivalent of the U.S
Constitution and those American ideals
codified in a software system now when I
say that people like oh my God this is
like crazy right what is this
bombastic statement but let me explain
so the U.S Constitution provides a
number of benefits uh and rights to
individuals including things like the
ability to pursue a life of Liberty
happiness uh a ability for free speech
an ability to have private property
rights things like that and so without
going through kind of in great detail uh
all these different documents if you
think of Bitcoin it basically provides
two specific things that are really
important the first is private property
rights we now have a way for you to hold
an asset in the digital world
and know that it is your asset and you
do not have to rely on a third party to
give it to you when you want
right even the dollars in the bank if
you go and they're like well we're not
issuing withdrawals today it's not your
money it's their money they owe it to
you but as we've seen uh you can't get
it out the same thing is true of pretty
much every digital asset you have right
uh outside of the analog world your
assets are sitting with someone else and
so this idea of having private property
that you control you own or this idea of
self-custody in Bitcoin uh is one key
kind of American value uh that is
implemented the second thing is free
speech so there are a number of
different cases
um that have gone all the way up to the
Supreme Court uh that have proven that
software is protected under the free
speech and so ultimately what you are
doing is you're just moving bits of
software back and forth that have
monetary value assigned to them but if I
want to send you a string of words
right and you would ascribe economic
value to it if I am prevented from doing
that then is my free speech right being
violated
it's a big question I talked to a number
of lawyers had him on the podcast they
believe yes they believe that stopping
someone from someone sending someone
else software uh that doesn't violate
other you know uh kind of violence or
whatever
uh is protected under the free speech
and so when you start to look at this
you're like okay those are like very
direct applicable things in terms of
Bitcoin structure and American rights or
or uh kind of uh values but then when
you zoom out and you look and you say
okay well what does America stand for
America stands for opportunity America
stands for capitalism and democracy and
all these different things Bitcoin is a
democratic system if there needs to be a
change to the code uh in terms of people
want to create software updates if
there's uh some sort of uh major
difference in what people want to do
it's up for vote it's literally a
democratic process there's not one
single owner there's not a company
there's an individual it is the holders
of Bitcoin end up all having a say uh
across miners node operators Etc
the second thing is uh Bitcoin is a free
market
what I mean by free market is even the
stock market in the United States which
we like to think of oh America Embraces
the free market if a stock is too
volatile the circuit breakers come out
right we have hours of operations we
have all these different things that
again there's a good reason like we
don't want humans up 24 7 365. uh you
know trying to trade stocks I get it
um but that ultimately is not a true
free market Bitcoin does trade 24 7 365
anyone can use it at any time there are
no circuit breakers just all these
things it's much more of that free
market kind of uh economics at play than
maybe otherwise
um and then the other thing that becomes
really interesting is actually Bitcoin
fulfills uh what is widely considered
the two critical criteria for a central
bank including the U.S Central Bank
which is for a central bank to be
effective it needs to one be independent
right we have presidents across both
sides of the aisle that are tweeting at
the central bank or calling the Central
Bank presidents in uh to their office
and kind of lecturing them and doing the
whole thing but it has to be independent
of the political environment and then
the second thing is it has to be
predictable
so if it has to be independent and
predictable if I was to put up any
Central Bank in the Fiat world next to
bitcoin I think most people would be
like no Bitcoin is definitely more
independent and more predictable which
ultimately fulfills uh kind of the the
responsibilities of the Central Bank in
a better manner for the American people
and so you kind of look at this and
you're like okay like this is like
getting into The Fringe kind of Bitcoin
Theory and and all that but if you go
and you talk to the politicians you say
hey if you really believe in the US
Constitution
what is the argument against it
and what you find is that like there's
not a lot that they kind of can stand on
and so naturally what happens is as with
most things in the world it's not black
and white it's kind of the culmination
of different things so you have people
who are holding it the White House
estimates about 15 of Americans have
Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies you have
this uh kind of appeal to the US
Constitution and individual rights that
are kind of baked into the system you
have the alignment with democracy and
capitalism which until somebody finds a
better system appears to be the best
system that humans have created and then
lastly is uh you're competing with
candidates
that are likely to be sympathetic to
this right if you're in a race and
there's 10 people somebody there is
going to be Pro Bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies
and so what you do is when you get to
this like intersection point of all
these things is I've just continued to
said like a bitcoiner will be president
but the bitcoiner probably isn't going
to run I'm like let's kill the US dollar
get rid of it and like we're going to
install Bitcoin as the national currency
what's more likely to happen is like
right now a stock investor is President
why because the guy who became president
owns stocks same thing with Bitcoin
right it's like somebody's gonna become
president like oh yeah I own some
Bitcoin okay uh and so understanding
that like these things have long
timelines is important as well and if
tons of young people are into it it just
naturally will take hold in positions of
power and influence you know 20 years
from now
I mean you've kind of seen it in the
city that you're living in Miami uh it's
been a strong pillar of uh the mayor's
kind of stature in the community and
kind of there's been a lot of people
looking in so I could see how that
scales all the way up to the White House
one day
yeah in Texas same way right Governor
Abbott I think has been a a pretty big
uh or at least maybe he's been
sympathetic I think to it and hasn't
tried to kind of uh squash uh Innovation
and and the economic work being done
there Texas is by far the mining capital
of the world now uh when it comes to
bitcoin uh all the oil and gas folks
seem to have really embraced it
um and you know that's just two states
in the United States right there's
plenty of other places that are doing
great things and so I I think it's
um it's inevitable but like people want
it to happen now and uh you know as as
you find out in life like little
patients could uh could surface all well